So, you want to be a copywriter. I get
it. You get to work from home. It costs
absolutely nothing to run a copywriting
business. And if you're really good, you
can become incredibly wealthy doing it.
But you get on the internet, you watch
all these YouTube videos, you buy a
couple courses, and you are more
confused than ever. I get it. That's
exactly where I was a couple years ago.
So, in this video, I'm [music] going to
break down a very simple stepbystep
process that you could follow to [music]
become a great copywriter today. And if
you're wondering if it's even worth it
to become a copywriter, I already made a
video on that. You can click the card
above to [music] watch that. But for
everyone else, let's go ahead and get
started with step one. Step one, study
the basics. [music]
I want you to buy this book. It's called
the AdWeek Copywriting Handbook. [music]
I don't want you to buy a bunch of
books. I want you to buy this book. It's
$24 on Amazon. Order it. I want you to
read it one time through. Don't take
notes. Just highlight, enjoy it, and
then read it a second time. Take notes.
Write down everything that you've
learned. Read it twice before moving to
step two. You have to understand the
basics before you can sell anything.
Step two, pick your first niche. Your
first niche is not your forever niche.
The best place to start is to pick a
niche where you are the target market.
Meaning you have spent money in this
niche or you have invested a lot of time
and interest in this niche. Do you like
the fitness industry, the supplement
industry, the golf industry? Because
you've already spent money and time in
this niche, you'll understand the pains,
hopes, and desires of [music] the target
audience better so you can write and
sell to them in the future. Step number
three is to [music] pick a service. You
should specialize in one of these three
types of copywriting. Emails, social
media ads, or website landing pages.
Those three services both have recurring
needs behind them, and you can easily
track whether you sell or not. So
customers will keep you on longer. Start
[music] by specializing in one of those
to create a higher desire for your
services. But in the beginning, if
somebody asks you to write for something
that you don't specialize in, that's
okay. Take it. It's not a big deal. But
when you promote yourself, promote
yourself as a specialist. Step number
four is build a portfolio. In your
portfolio, you need a headsh shot, a
bio, your [music] specialization,
examples of your work, and a way for
people to contact you. [music] In fact,
if you want, I went ahead and created a
notion portfolio template for you. Link
in the description below. I This is
actually my real portfolio from a couple
of years ago that I used to send and
text and put on Upwork and things like
this. You could just take it, change the
words, change the picture, change the
bio, all that stuff, and use it for
yourself. But that begs the question,
well, what are you going to put in it?
This is where I want you to start
[music] doing spec work. Okay, so if you
picked your niche and you picked your
service, let's do spec work based on
that. Let's say the niche that you
picked is supplements. You buy a lot of
supplements. You know a lot about the
industry. Let's say the service you
picked is emails. So now what I want you
to do is I want you to subscribe to the
email list of supplement companies that
you like. And then I want you to take
their emails and I want you to rewrite
them to be better emails. This is called
spec work or example [music] work. The
companies didn't actually hire you to do
the work, but that doesn't mean you
can't do work [music] for them anyway.
You write a bunch of emails, let's say
10, 15, 20 emails of spec work for
supplement brands. And then [music] put
your best five in your portfolio. And at
the top of each email, make sure to
label it as spec work. You're not lying.
You're being honest. Hey, they didn't
actually hire me to do this [music]
work, but I wrote these emails. At the
end of the day, nobody really cares
whether they hired you or not. But if
the emails are really good, they could
still hire you based on some work that
you've made. Now that you've got a
portfolio, you know your niche, you know
what service [music] you have, and
you've studied the basics, let's go get
a client. Step five. Step five, get on
Upwork. There's two really prime ways to
get clients in the very beginning. One,
you can text your network and ask them
for referrals, which is really good. Or
you can get on platforms like Fiverr or
Upwork. I've noticed that Upwork seems
to be a very good platform for
copywriters. The reason I like the
Upwork path for you [music] is because
people are looking for you instead of
you looking for them. So, it reverses
the chase. And whether people want to
admit it or not, the chase is probably
the most discouraging part to
copywriters starting in the beginning.
So, while it makes logical sense to ask
your network for referrals, it's
actually way less daunting to just get
on Upwork, have a great portfolio, and
have people reach out to us. When you
get on Upwork, make sure to have a
professional headsh shot, great bio, put
your notion portfolio in there, all that
great stuff to set up yourself for
success. Then what I want you to do is I
want you to price yourself at $1.
[music] I want you to say that you'll
take on any project in your niche or
specialization for $1. And then I want
you to be really honest while you're
doing that. Tell people that you are a
new copywriter that has mastered the
fundamentals and you are willing to work
for essentially free to [music] collect
testimonials. People will respect that
and they will give you a shot because of
[music] your price point, your
professionalism, your portfolio. Then I
want you to do that for [music] five
clients. Okay? Work for $1 on five
projects. [music] And I want you to
collect testimonials on all five of
those projects. And I want you to create
case studies. And a case study is simply
[music] before me, this was the results
they were getting. After me, these are
the results they're getting. With five
testimonials and five case studies that
you can put in your portfolio, you can
now charge a chunky sum for your
services. Because the biggest barrier to
charging money for copywriting is the
[music] risk that the people paying you
have to take. Why should I pay this
copywriter money if I [music] don't know
if it's going to work? But with case
studies and testimonials, they look at
that and say, "Wow, this is probably
going to work. I'm going to pay them
money." If you want a more indepth
[music] tutorial on how to crush Upwork,
my friend Daniel Thrasell has a course
called Upwork [music] in 1 hour. I
highly recommend it if you want to go
further on this subject. Step six, scale
your [music] income. There's two ways to
make more money as a copywriter. You can
get more clients or you can upsell your
current clients. I prefer the latter. I
want you to upsell your current clients.
Remember in the beginning of this where
I told you to pick a specialization?
Well, that's because I want to open up
the opportunity later for you to upsell
[music] the other two services. So, if
you're writing emails for a supplement
company, now you can go to that
supplement company, which you've already
gotten results, and say, "Hey, what do
you think about me writing your Facebook
and Instagram ads, your Tik Tok ads,
your website landing page for your new
launch, your new products?" [music] That
way, you can have less clients paying
you more money instead of a bunch of
clients paying you a little bit of
money. The other thing you can do is you
can ask your current clients for
referrals, even the ones that you did
work for $1. You can offer them more
paid services saying, "Hey, since I did
this for you for $1 and got great
results, what if I do this for x amount
of dollars and get even better results?"
Or you can say, "Hey, since I did this
project for you for $1 and got amazing
results, do you know anybody just like
you that also needs amazing results with
copyrightiting?" So, there's referrals,
there's upsells, and there's more
inquiries coming at you via Upwork
because you're getting ratings, you're
adding case studies. Every time you do
work for a new [music] client, you
create a case study behind it, and you
raise your prices by at least 25 to 50%.
Because you're getting better, and
because you're getting better means
you're getting them better results. So,
you should be charging more money for
those better results. Eventually, you
get 10, 15, 20 of those clients and you
start getting referrals without
outreach. You don't need Upwork anymore.
[music] Your website portfolio becomes
more advanced and you can make a
full-time income working from home
writing words on the internet. That's
it. Six steps. I hope that was helpful
for you. Don't forget to grab the
portfolio template down below. And
another gift for you. I [music] have a
copywriting guide, Copywriting Catalyst.
It's absolutely free where I teach you
63 [music] cash cow copywriting secrets
that I've learned over my journey of
becoming an expert copywriter. If you
enjoyed this video, I ask take one
second, hit the like below and [music]
subscribe to the channel to tell me that
you want more videos like this. Till
next time, I'll see you on the next one.
God, that was a good video, man. I am
good at this stuff. I feel like I feel
like I'm just slapping. This could have
been This could have been like one of
those like $97 [music]
guru courses. You know what I'm talking
about? Where they're like they're like
the this is so valuable. This is this is
amazing. It is valuable. It is valuable,
but like I'm putting it on YouTube for
free. They're like putting it in a
Google doc with Chhat GPT. They're like,
"ChachiPT made this amazing course for
me and I'm selling it for $97." You know
what I did? I used my brain. I used my
brain [music] and experience. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So, what I did was I I told
you what I learned based on like
actually doing it instead of just
prompting chat GPT for like a
step-by-step course. It's crazy what
like actually living and uh doing
doing this whole like copyrighted thing
yourself. It's crazy how much you learn
just like doing the real thing. It's
wild. Absolutely wild.